stop before you're about to accept islam
you must listen to me
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the night east
stop before you're about to accept islam
you must listen to me i'm a revert to
islam
i'm a muslim myself but before you
take your shahada you must watch this
brothers and sisters welcome to this
video i'll be discussing something very
important
yesterday three videos were released
three videos two of them of
one christian islamophobe one
atheist islamophobe who claims to be an
ex-muslim which is outright
lie he was never a muslim ever in his
life
and another one who's uh who's a david
wood wannabe basically i'm not even
gonna mention his name
this guy here it's just a guy who's just
like literally begging you know got
he's trying his best so we're just gonna
disregard him he's not even someone
that's important yeah the
rest the remaining the other two they're
not important as well but i found it
very interesting
that these three people
literally i watched all of their videos
three other videos
and in their videos they are literally
begging
you yes the ones who are watching this
who are on the virtue except in islam
they are literally saying this to you
please don't accept islam
please don't accept islam hey look we'll
do a shotgun method we'll just mention
all these verses out of context
please don't accept islam hey islam says
kill destruction
and murder please don't accept islam
please don't islam says you have to beat
your wife's up
islam says you can have four wives islam
says
this and that's about women and women
has no rights please
please don't accept islam and when that
was happening i was thinking to myself
is that you know when you have like
like i don't know like just scenario
yeah
you know a little haram scenario you
know you're in a relationship you know
with this girlfriend of yours you know
and she's like
please don't leave me please i'll do
whatever you want me to do
please please just just don't leave
whatever you want
that is how bad the desperation has got
has gotten
now i want to say something very
interesting because i was watching one
of the video and look how allah
plans guys please just tune in look how
allah plans that i was watching one of
his videos let's check this out listen
to this guy
listen to this here on this video look
listen to this carefully
number two is beneficial knowledge that
a person leaves behind
and number three is a righteous
offspring that will make dua for their
parents once they have departed from
this life
well this is a video of why you should
not
accept islam yeah these three main
videos released at once because it was
an emergency because
there's hundreds thousands millions in
latin america
to you name it to all over the world
people are coming to islam to
big youtubers to speak at school in
speaker's corner i have never come
across one person
one person that's come to any other
faith as much as they come to islam and
in his video of telling people not to
accept islam there is an
ad and the ad is of a prophet doing tawa
according to islam
and this is what allah says they plan
and i plan
and i am the best of planners
alhamdulillah i know you don't like to
hear this
yeah in the very video there's an ad so
you have to watch the ad
it's a five second ad you have to watch
and in the ad would you say
the brother's giving the hour he's
giving down
subhan allah imagine you're doing a
video and putting all the effort in
and youtube has to places that at five
seconds
and it's giving dawah it's giving darwa
i found that amazing and there is a
massive reply before i'm going to get
into the main clocks of the matter of
reverts because this video is not
clickbait reversed before you
accept islam you need to listen to what
i'm about to say i'm going to wrap it up
quickly here
quran chapter 110 allah says
[Music]
[Music]
what does allah say when allah
ultimately helps cut when when allah's
ultimate help comes
and the victory over mecca is achieved
and you o prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam see the people embracing
allah's
ways in crowds in multitudes in millions
and in billions
and in multitudes
the praise of your lord and seek his
forgiveness
for certainty for certainly he is
never accepting he is for certainly he
is ever accepting of repentance
so brothers and sisters we want to make
this video a video of where you guys
alhamdulillah subhanallah
glorify allah as we can see multitude of
people
coming to islam multitude of people
coming to islam brothers and sisters
there's a book called beauty sick as i
read this book it makes perfect sense to
me why so many women come to islam
because the society they live in have
sexualized and objectified them to a
level
that no one actually respects them they
are
treated like a piece of meat and that's
why it makes so much sense that
women are flocking to islam can you
believe the miracle the campaign that's
done
towards islam and towards how they've
made it out like
the way women are treated and the
opposite
and the more women are coming to islam
so for those reavers who are watching
this
for those who are on the verge of
accepting islam hold on a second let me
tell you something as a revert
when i came to islam while i'm telling
you guys
this is exactly what happened yeah i was
stopped
i'm not going to mention who it was
cross family members yeah
i was forced i was even before i was uh
came to some i wanted to try far out
fasting
i was insulted i was sworn at i was
abused
i was kicked out my house i was called
isis i was mocked up i was laughed i was
called an idiot i was caught everything
under the sun
all these doubts they came with shotgun
method like these guys did
shotgun oh he said he killed me there
are all this nonsense
all of them came and every time i had an
answer
to it evidence not hearsay evidence you
know what was called
while i asked you upon the lord of the
kaab if i'm like
you know what they would say to me yeah
after i would
i would i would give them the the the
reply you know what they say to me oh
you're an idiot don't get aggressive
with me
family members close family members
you're idiot
you're stupid you're dumb you're dumb
you're following this prophet
who's like this is like the audebilla
the greatest man to walk this earth
these men some of them in my family
members yes male members will come and
tell me
oh you know uh um your religion says
that you can have four wives that are et
cetera and i'm thinking in my head bruv
no disrespect yeah like this some of
them are very vile towards the person
yeah and i'm looking at his family
member by mayo and i think brother are
you not the same guy who cheated on your
wife
three four times above are you not the
same guy and you're here coming and
telling me
about a woman's rights are you not the
same guy who beats his wife black and
blue above
and you're the one coming and mocking me
yeah mocking me
go to my wife and tell if i've ever laid
my hand on her ever
treated her how you treat your wife now
i'm not saying that it's just muslims
that do it and
you need islam in the context of yeah
there are some good guys out there
the point is this hypocrisy when allah
legislates for a man to marry two three
times etc
yeah it's because to honor if it's gonna
be done it's gonna be done in the right
way that you don't go and abuse
use and abuse another a woman yeah you
have your main wife and you've got
sidetracks and mysteries and girlfriends
that you use it abuse
and treat them like crap and destroy
them psychologically and mentally
yeah and you just use them and chuck
them away allah says no
if it's going to be done it's going to
be done the right way you honor her you
marry her you honor her
so i'm just saying guys for those who on
the verge of accepting islam
let me tell you something the only thing
that you should be concerned about is
what you know what
have no doubt islam is the truth no
shadow of a doubt
no shadow of a doubt islam is the truth
the only thing that you need to concern
about is the persecution that you're
going to suffer
yeah because i've heard of river stories
of rivers being spat in the face
kicked out their house yeah our brother
issa may i love mercy and he passed away
yeah he's found one of his family
members were letting pray he would go
and pray in the garden
so don't worry about these things once
you know islam is the truth
the only thing that they're going to be
left with just as the quraish the pagan
arabs lifted the prophet peace be upon
him and tortured him
and his companions for 13 years and
killed them and
touch them for what
just because of this statement i myself
as a reaver
was persecuted myself not like that i'm
not trying to make it dramatic
i went through some stuff as well but
the main message is this
you this is the same thing you're going
to go through yeah you might do you
might i'm not saying
and walking out on the streets of the
hijabi getting attacked
these are the things sadly we have to be
concerned about not is islam the truth
or not
i speak to a lot of reavers that's not
their concern because they know islam is
the truth they're concerned about
as a hijabi or only walking down the
road and being spattered
being run over being shot when you're in
the mosque yeah
being shot being uh um being vilified
yeah
being being kicked out yeah
losing your family members having to
pray having to pray in secret
these are the things rivers have to be
concerned about so before you accept
islam
know that this these things should never
stop you from accepting islam allah is
going to make you strong
and while i shall say something as a
revere myself seven gone in eight years
alhamdulillah may allah keep us firm
on the shadow of him
every single second of that persecution
that little persecution that i went
through was damn worth it
it is downward increased my iman
increased my iman knowing
that these people these people have
nothing
be my own family members to these
islamophobes
to these scumbags on the roads attacking
sisters and brothers innocent people
stabbing people killing people the only
thing they fear is
while they fear that that's why they
burn qurans that's where they insult the
prophet that's why they draw pictures
that's why they do all the things all
these things you know why because
they've got
nothing else in their hands so much so
that three people who've done this video
one of them is an atheist imagine
atheist siding with two christians
imagine and this is how they'll come
together all of them will come together
and these two christians yeah one
there's a little boy here trying to be
david wood
yeah and what do they they've stopped
talking about christianity
they don't talk about christianity
anymore you know why because people have
come to the realization
a sister accepted islam and you can
check this video out um
the um she's the stepdaughter of a
pastor yeah
okay pastor not pastor yeah pastor she
accepted islam
why because she said and look at there
were some studies done in america
majority a lot of the christians they
don't believe jesus is actually divine
they don't believe it so people are not
buying that and the west have turned
their back against christianity
so what these hate preachers do these
christian approaches by the way they're
not the same because allah says in the
quran
[Music]
the people of the book are not the same
the process of salam said there is not a
muslim servant of allah who says this
three times in the morning and evening
except that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
will be pleased with them under their
judgment
welcome to islam may allah make your
path easy and do not let
these hate-filled preachers stop you let
them
beg please don't accept islam because
what they're doing
is actually causing more people to learn
about islam till next time i've got to
go
my daughter's back assalamu alaikum
we're better too
yeah come here you're my camera woman
come come
until next time goodbye